-The "In The Heights" opened i
theaters this weekend,
the musical about a Dominica
and Puerto Rican neighborhoo
in New York City.
One of our writers, Jenny Hagel,
is Puerto Rican, and she's her
to review it for us.
-[ Sobbing ]
-Oh, oh, oh, God.
Jenny, are you okay?
-[ Crying ] Yeah, I'm fine
Seth.
I just -- I saw "In The Heights"
yesterday
and it was really beautiful.
-Okay, well, you know,
do you think you
can tell us about it?
-Okay.
There was singing and there wa
-- there was dancing.
-Okay...
-And there were all these Latinx
people and they felt so prou
of who they are,
and it was so beautiful.
-Uh-huh, and did that make you
a little emotional?
-Y-Y-Yes.
-To see all those Latinx peopl
feeling so good about
themselves?
-Uh-huh.
-And was that emotion mayb
heightened by the realizatio
that you don't get to see that
on the screen very often?
-Mm-hmmm.
-Alright, well, that's great
You want to tell us anything
else about the movie?
-T-There were parts where
they spoke in Spanish,
and there weren't any subtitles,
and it was beautiful
because it made you feel lik
Spanish isn't
a foreign language,
it's just as much a part o
America as English,
and we're all American.
-Okay.
-And then -- And then --
-And then what?
-There was -- There was -- There
was a full screen close up o
an entire flan.
-A what?
-A flan!
It's a Latin dessert and there
was one shot where the fla
took up the whole screen,
and there was nothing on scree
but the flan.
-And -- And why are you crying
about that?
-Because my mommy makes flan
and I haven't seen her all yea
because of the pandemic.
-Jenny, would it help you if
we talk about something else
-Uh-huh.
-Okay.
-Well, this is your first time
back in the theater
after the pandemic,
how was that?
-Um, that was good.
When I got to the theater, i
felt good to be around people.
When the lights went down,
they played this little vide
where the cast of
"In The Heights"
tells you they know you've had
a hard year,
and then they all say
"Welcome back to the movies.
-Oh, you know what?
Okay, Jenny.
Why don't you go back.
You want to go back to work?
-I can't, I have tickets t
another screening
that starts in 10 minutes.
-Jenny Hagel, everybody.
Thank you so much, and thank you
also for wearing mascara.
It helped.
-[ Crying ] Okay.
[ Crying ]
-[ Laughs ]